all right so this is Isabella from
Dallas Texas okay a 23 year old
entertainer entertainers in quotes and
vo she loves you your favorite and they
want about strippers they want you to
rate that stripper from rape my strip
now which one is Izzy on the left of the
right I believe is he is our girl on the
with the rainbow with the rainbow - -
okay okay got that thick rainbow all
right that taste the rainbow that
ROYGBIV huh
it's um the king-sized freakin skittles
baby that's those uh now and laters
remember toes [ __ ] yeah they weren't
that great no they weren't they look
like a box of runts over here these are
two young women trying to make it in
society now the one on the Left can get
it though she wants to share well she
was sure a bag of [ __ ] Mike and Ikes
hit me up girl what does that mean run a
train who's Ike bro here's what I'm
saying I'm Mike and Ike do both of these
ladies one of them is wearing a nightie
one of them is wearing more of like a
has very like a kind of a clownish sort
of outdoorsy maybe Raven my brave they
look like two chicks that went to fire
festival and [ __ ] God dis up we near
they're still there yeah they look like
a couple of fire festival lifers yeah
still still doing live instagrams from
fire festival gym just barbecue and
outdoors but a couple of them just
barbecue in coconut now terawatt man's
probably think the same thing I won't go
on make him afraid just lose the pounds
that's what it takes from your lose
weight I'll do it they get afraid I
could see you on there bro
I'll get my cheeks out I don't want that
I just want to see how you survive you
and I could do naked afraid but you
don't go to us to be naked you could be
naked at home he's a link when you go to
be afraid yeah I would be afraid of the
dark nobody's there dust like their
first day this modelling around the lane
it would be pull-ups on the tree this
[ __ ] Nam excited
this and then don't bring a hot chick
man I don't get how the dudes just
aren't like I don't know what to tell
you I've seen [ __ ] hyenas all goddamn
week you and your fine ass comes up with
this blonde ass oh you mean if a chick
what do you mean
don't bring a hot chick or do or what do
you say what do you mean I'd like a hot
chick there but then also forgive me you
know I'm saying no I don't that's why
I'm asking you I don't understand
exactly what you're I'm saying I'm
trapped on this island right 21 days
butt naked yeah with some like dime
piece me prom son dude no dime is going
on there without some mental issues I
don't thing going on naked and afraid
exactly so these two need to figure it
out they need to figure it out Lord what
are the thoughts is that where you going
Lord of the thighs that's panning down
I think these bad [ __ ] are on drugs
dude and I'm drug free and so I can't be
out there out there watching y'all do
all the dust and everything out there
and licking each other's thighs and ass
you know not one on left let's get a bag
of pop rocks and figure it out girl now
Kat what do you got to say when you see
these types of ladies oh I love it
Asian girls always come dressed like
that for rapes always and do Asians love
raises their uh yes wonjun's love raves
uh ecstasy hell yeah [ __ ] clothes and
fake tits yeah check check check
yeah yeah I'm a giant asian girl yeah
dude we found something new [ __ ] yeah
what uh so uh that's great ever been to
a rave huh
yeah yeah yeah way bad Wednesday they
beats me out with a chain at it one time
like this is horrible
do you not want to array one time
there's eight people it's sad it's in
Hollywood there's eight people we stayed
up all night man
it's not a raid dude you may be right
but there was a DJ though clapping I put
up a banner but i but i but i was on the
dance floor like this Oh
I got caught at a place looking for dope
one time with some lady I remember what
happened and I don't know man I don't
know what happened
well King these ladies yeah what do they
need money to for the fair weather we
had uber home what's going on here thank
you ladies for the love y'all seem like
decent women and I think at a certain
point I like strippers now if they're
strippers here look get out there and
make your money but also I think you
need to have some sort of long-term exit
strategy because at some point the tits
don't lie sometimes the tits give up and
your ass falls back you know I'm saying
then eat then the money stops that's
yeah that's what I'm saying - yeah so
but I didn't know I always agen girls
always made me feel like they're not
interested I think cuz I don't know
their vibe at all you know like white
girls and black girls I can tell more
their vibe because I grew up around them
Asians always look the same yeah like I
never know what I don't know cats in a
good mood or bad mood really always
looks the same no I don't think that I
think I can tell it's not a racial thing
but it's good I know calibrator maybe
it's cuz I don't know a lot of but yeah
a lot of Asian girls they say it never
seemed interested they never look at you
dude I got you you just start talking
about anime they freak the [ __ ] out
really oh dude it's such a turn-on I
don't know anything about it me neither
just say Pokemon or some [ __ ] uh-uh not
be amazing Pokemon again - how old are
these women I don't know see that
something you don't know their age
either well I'm gonna know I see doesn't
it sounds like it does yeah Jesus good
luck with the Asians yeah me good luck
not turning your diary over to police
you're in trouble
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]